I think that this is the best answer.
The problem with this answer, even though it may seem appealing initially,
is that without knowing the true circumference, this number--34,000 km--
is sort of meaningless.
What if the earth had a circumference of 10 bajillion km?
Well, then an error of 34,000 km would be nothing in comparison to that.
So, I really have to reference point for what this number means.
This is actually a pretty good description of Plato's error--
that the true circumference is about half.
But this one's a little better, because it gives me a little more precision.
I have an actual number. Plato's guess was 85% larger than the true circumference.
This is the best statement of error.